so there's another theory i have
and this applies to cancer culture it's
a branding issue
okay it's a branding issue if you put
yourself
out as someone and i buy into that and
then i find out
you're not the person you sold me as i'm
out i'm [ __ ] out forever i can't
deal with that i think that's part of
the reason i have a hard time quitting
drinking
is because everyone knows that i like to
have a drink and i party
and i feel like the second i
and i think a lot of my fans are people
that you know a little overweight have a
beard have a hotter wife than they
deserve
they like to party they get their lives
you know they can get [ __ ] done but
they could do better but like i think
that's you know not not to speak
at a school about anything but that was
what happened with aziz
when because he came out is this like i
don't i i don't
i'm not trying to talk [ __ ] about aziz i
know that he went through a lot with
that [ __ ] i'm
not trying to add it like that but like
as far as like the you know
whatever the let me let's do louis louis
a better example okay
see louie louise told himself is this
dirt bag i'm a dirt bag i'm a piece of
[ __ ] that's who i am
everyone believed it but they didn't
really believe it they were like oh he's
a great guy he's a great guy and then
when he's like no
i jerked off in front of a couple chicks
everyone's like what the [ __ ]
and it's their in their their branding
comes out different
in their head you know aziz was this
woke bae like
i'm a feminist i'm a feminist and then
it turns out you know he likes to get
[ __ ] funky with chicks and put their
fingers in their mouth in their [ __ ]
well
that did the branding dis disassociated
his fans that's when you lose fans is
when your branding comes off wrong
but you can't lose fans by being a
fuck-up i'm hearing you say that you
identify
that as like your identity like it's
like i think a lot of people
it's like if you found out i mean look
at [ __ ] james hadfield
james hadfield was 100 beer in his hand
every concert the whole time
cheers to the crowd like was anybody
[ __ ] mad at him for stopping drinking
yeah no no but i think he was what was
he like 50 something when he stopped
no god no dude they were like 18 years
right yeah
not granted he just went back to rehab
but um
dude [ __ ] it was uh they made this
some kind of monster
movie and uh that was like i want to say
2005 or something so 15 years ago he did
he wasn't
50 years old 15 years ago and and i
remember too
that uh i just got my little nine month
chip
you know yeah and at the time whenever
after i got sober in 2008 and i went to
metallica concert and they brought me
backstage to meet james hedfield he was
in his own like little space
dude was just glowing man you could see
sobriety like all over i mean
you know he made it look so good it
glows on you man well thanks
it glows on you by the way i look like
garbage right now
because i drank all morning this morning
[Laughter]
i mean but just a quick story i told him
i asked him how long had he been sober
and he said seven years
at that point this was in uh december of
2008. so he gets over in 2001
and um i said dude just got my nine
months chip and i pulled it out it's
this little plastic
like round like poker chip kind of thing
and you get plastic ones and then
and then when it's a gear it's a metal
medallion and i i
saw him like my nine-month chip i said
no more plastic for me
straight heavy metal from here on out
like which was my way of saying that i
you know i was gonna like
be diligent and do the work of sobriety
but dude i just like
i mean don't don't feel like you owe it
to your [ __ ] fans to
keep drinking like i mean dude if it's
time if it's time to stop it's time to
stop it
it'll be man i'm i'm i'm
i i can feel that around the corner i
just feel
i feel like i feel like i'm i look at
myself and i go like dude don't be like
everything you just said about about
betraying brands
like i buy it i buy it because it's like
it's one thing
if if you're [ __ ] not genuine it's
one thing if you're
if you [ __ ] lie to people if you're
[ __ ] if i choose to stop drinking it
and
then i'm i'm cool with it i think i
think people would still come see me
what am i worried about of course of
course for me it's like it's like i
i feel like i'm still so young in in in
everything
even though i'm old but like like i go
out to bars with the
my fans after the shows i invite them
all to a bar
how many of these people in the theaters
are you like taking photos with remember
i've never seen you tweeting like who's
got a good way of meeting like a
thousand people
yeah i do i do a raffle
for the meet and greet so everyone can
buy you can buy as many tickets as you
want
and uh and we pull 20 names they can
bring as many people as they want we do
that meet and greet
and then i name a bar in the city and i
go to that bar
oh my god what a nightmare what a
[ __ ] nightmare like you haven't
already
no [ __ ] if you weren't drunk it'd be
you'd be like [ __ ] i get high before i
go
smoke a little weed and then it just
it's like there's a i just
like this and so um i mean yeah
maybe i maybe take well we talked about
last night i maybe take about 500
pictures
right they're probably throughout the
night it's by the way i don't mind that
what really bothers me is the person who
gets four or five pictures with me
it's like one more man i'm like we
already got it like please
okay so so you feel like you need to
hang on to drinking as an
identity
but you didn't have any problem with uh
like
i love summer october and then you use
all of a sudden you start getting like
fit
yeah yeah yeah i love sober october but
sober october is a it's a it's
you know it's a it's a game it's like a
fun everyone knows that the rules do it
no drugs no alcohol fitness
you know what's crazy is that when it
comes up i always think oh
harsh and then i'm like wait a second
i'm sober all year long
i love super october i every time i get
done super october i go i might be dumb
forever
how how many how long have you felt like
quitting drinking is just around the
corner
because i remember when you came over to
watch the special at thieves
yeah you were saying like i think it was
like sober october
october yeah and you were like uh you
know i think this might be it
every every summer october i go this is
it and then and then i get drunk that
first time and i [ __ ] hate it
i hate to wake up the next morning why
am i doing this to myself
and then uh and then it i don't know it
just creeps back into your life
yeah dude